Уявімо, що громадська активістка Марія
вирішує пройти безкоштовний тест на ВІЛ,
гарантований державою,
однак їй у цьому відмовляють.
Це анімаційне відео про те, як пересічний українець
може проконтролювати державні закупівлі.
На прикладі вигаданої історії про дівчину,
якій відмовили у безкоштовному тесті на ВІЛ,
автори у двохвилинному відео продемонстрували покроково,
як викрити зловживання закупівельників за допомогою
двох основних моніторингових сайтів
- DOZORRO та BI.PROZORRO.
Марія знаходить відповідну медичну установу
у системі і з'ясовує що торги з
закупівлі тестів були проведені.
Автори не приховують, їхня мета - залучити
якомога більше громадян до процесу контролювання держави.
Щоб не лише журналісти чи активісти,
а кожен міг просто і доступно
перевірити публічні закупівлі.
Мета - донести той факт,  що сьогодні контролювати
державу і контролювати те, як витрачаються
наші з громадянами кошти - тому що
нема такого поняття як кошти держави,
це все кошти платників податків -    стало надзвичанйо просто.
Наразі щомісяця близько п’ятнадцяти
тисяч людей відвідують обидва портали
і близько півтисячі залишають скарги на сайті.
Втім, автори системи кажуть – цього замало.
Інструменти перевірок, які є в розпорядженні українців,
одні з найкращих у світі.
І тому заохочують громадян користуватись ними активніше.
Ба більше, без допомоги юристів чи активістів.
Насправді наша мета не отримувати велику кількість скарг.
Тому що ми хочемо дати інструмент людям у руки.
Тому що одне діло це поскаржитись у системі
і розраховувати, що юристи
проекту DOZORRO чи Transparency International Україна
зроблять роботу для вас, а інша справа це скористатись
інструкціями, які вже розроблені у нас на порталі,
і писати скаргу не на систему,
а безпосередньо у котролюючий орган,
який може вплинути на ті чи інші зміни.
У майбутньому автори розробки у Transparency
планують запровадити оформлення скарги на закупівлю -
до поліції та в інші органи - в режимі онлайн.
Без необхідності роздруковувати скаргу
і нести до поліції.